[موسيقى]
في ظل تنافس محبوم بين الولايات المتحده
من جهه وروسيا والصين من جهه اخرى لجذب
حلفاء واصدقاء جدد كل الى معسكره تتواصل
الاستعدادات على قدم وساق في جوهانسبورغ
بجنوب افريقيا لعقد قمه في اغسطس المقبل
تضم رؤساء خمس دول تشكل ما يعرف بمجموعه
هذه القمه تحظى باهتماما كبير لان على
جدول او على راس جدول اعمالها بالتحديد
فتحه باب العضويه امام دول جديده بعضها
يتميز بثقل اقتصاديا ومالي وبعضها الاخر
بثقل سكانيا وعسكري هي المكاسب السياسيه
والاقتصاديه التي قد تحققها مجموعه بريكس
عبر توسيع عضويتها والى اي حد قد يعزز ذلك
ذلك مكانتها على ساحه الدوليه كقوه ناشئه
منافسه لمجموعه السبع ومهدده لهيمنتها على
الاقتصاد
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قبل نحو اسبوعا استضافت
مدينه كيب تاون في جنوب افريقيا اجتماعا
لوسراء خارجيه دول مجموعه بريكس خلال هذا
الاجتماع تمت مناقشه موضوعات كثيره من
بينها زياده مجالات التعاون بين دول
بالاضافه الى نقطتين رئيسيتين وما توسيع
العضويه وبحث امكانيه انشاء عمله موحده
للتبادل التجاريه عن اهميه هذا التكاتل
الاقتصادي ومستقبله والدول المرشحه اكثر
للانضمام اليه في القمه المقبله يسعدنا ان
يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور ماجد التركي رئيس مركز الاعلام
والدراسات العربيه الروسيه من موسكو اندري
كورتنوف رئيس المجلس الروسي للعلاقات
الدوليه ومن مشجن الدكتور مصطفى شاهين
استاذ الاقتصاد في كليه اوكلاند الامريكيه
فاهلا بهم جميعا
مجموعه بريكس والدول المنضويه حاليا تحت
روائها وهي روسيا والصين والهند والبرازيل
وجنوب افريقيا تقدم نفسها كتكتل اقتصادي
يسعى لكسر هيمنه الغرب على الاقتصاد
العالمي ويتوقع العديد من خبراء الاقتصاد
انها ستكون رمزا للاقتصادات الاسرع نموا
في العالم في المستقبل القريب
مجموعه بريكس تكتل اقتصادي عالمي بدات
فكره تاسيسه في سبتمبر من عام 2006 حينما
عقد اول اجتماع وزاري لوزراء خارجيه
البرازيل وروسيا والهند والصين على هامشي
اشغال الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في
نيويورك
يضم هذا التكتل خمس دول تعد صاحبه اسرع
نمو اقتصادي في العالم
وكلمه بريكس بالانجليزيه عباره عن اختصار
يضم الاحرف الاولى من اسماء هذه الدول
اصبحت مجموعه بريكس احد اهم التكتلات
الاقتصاديه في العالم نظرا لارقام النمو
التي باتت تحققها دول هذا التكتل مع توالي
السنوات في يونيو 2009 عقد اول اجتماع على
مستوى القمه بين هذه الدول تشكل دول
مجموعه بريكس مجتمعه نحو 40% من مساحه
العالم ويعيش فيها اكثر من 40% من سكان
الكره الارضيه حيث تضم اكبر خمس دول مساحه
في العالم واكثرها كثافه سكانيه تهدف
المجموعه الى ان تصبح قوه اقتصاديه عالميه
قادره على منافسه مجموعه السبع التي
تستحوذ على نحو 60% من الثروه العالميه
بالنسبه للهيكليه الاقتصاديه قررت
المجموعه في قمه 2014
انشاء بنك تنميه سمي بنك الجديد وصندوق
احتياطي في شنغهاي بعشرات المليارات خلال
قمه بريكس عام 2017 لوكيش مصطلح على
تسميتها بخطه التي ترمي الى اضافه دول
جديده للمجموعه وفي مارس الماضي ادت اكثر
من 13 دوله رغبتها في الانضمام الى
المجموعه من بينها السعوديه والامارات
ومصر والجزائر وايران والارجنتين والمكسيك
ونيجيريا وغيرها في يونيو 2022 اعلن
الرئيس الروسي ان دول مجموعه الى اطلاق
عمله موحده بينها تنهي بها هيمنه الدولار
الامريكي ولم تحسم دول بريكس بعد شكل
العمله الجديده التي ستقوم على اساس
استراتيجي وتامينها سيكون بالاعتماد على
الذهب والمعادن النفيسه
[موسيقى]
الى جنوب افريقيا ستشد الانظار في اغسطس
المقبل حيث القمه الخامسه عشره لرؤساء دول
وحكومات مجموعه بريكس لن تكون كسابقاتها
هذه المره على طاوله زعماء هذه الدول
خيارات مصيريه قد تحدث في حال اعتمادها
ثوره على ثوابت النظام الاقتصادي العالمي
سيناقشون بالاساس احتمال انضمام اعضاء جدد
الى المجموعه وفي القائمه ما لا يقل عن 16
دوله تريد مقعدا لها ضمن هذا التكتل من
حيث حجم اقتصاداتها فان اللائحه الثقيله
بوجود دول النفطيه مهمه كالسعوديه
والامارات ونيجيريا وذاك مؤشر لتوجه متنام
لدى الدول الناميه نحو ايجاد خيارات
اقتصاديه بديله لهيمنه الدول الصناعيه
الغربيه الكبرى
لكن قضيه مناقشه العمله الموحده واستخدام
العملات المحليه في التجاره البينيه قد
تكون وقعا على سيروره الاقتصاد العالمي
انها رغبه متعاظمه في التحرر من هيمنه
الدولار على التعاملات الماليه الدوليه
ومن شروط البنك الدولي للاقراض ولذلك اعلن
عام 2015 تاسيس بنك التنميه الجديد الذي
تراسه ديلماروسيف رئيسه البرازيل السابقه
ومهمته تمويل مشاريع البنيه التحتيه
والتنميه المستدامه في دول البريكس
والبلدان الناميه كل هذه الرهانات
الاقتصاديه لا تلغي وجود حسابات سياسيه في
تقويه مجموعه بريكس فالقمه الاخيره
لمجموعه السبع في هيروشيما اليابانيه
اصدرت بيانا شديدا لهجه ضد الصين وروسيا
ولعل ذلك يدفع الدولتين نحو مزيد من
الاستقطاب في ظل رغبه الواضحه لدى الدول
الناميه في عالم متعدد الاقطاب
تعلم الدول الغربيه جيدا ان ايا من الدول
الاعضاء في مجموعه بريكس لم توافق على
ادانه الحرب التي تشنها روسيا على
اوكرانيا في الامم المتحده لذلك ينظر
غربيا الى تنامي كتله بريكس على انه
يستهدف تسريع تراجع نفوذ الولايات المتحده
في العالم ليس اقتصاديا فحسب بل سياسيا
ايضا
هل الطريق الان مفتوح امام هذا التكتل
لتحقيق اهدافه ربما من المبكر الاجابه عن
هذا التساؤل ثم تترقب لما قد يقره زعماء
المجموعات في قمه اغسطس ولاي معايير يمكن
اعتمادها لقبول عضويه دول جديده في ظل
التباين في حجم اقتصادات الدول المرشحه
وتاثيراتها اقليميا ودوليا
دكتور ماجد التركي اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه الدول التي تطمح للالتحاق بمجموعه
بريكس ما الذي تريده بالضبط
مساء الخير او ما الذي تطمع فيه بالاحر
ربما هو في المرحله الحاليه هو ليس مطمع
بقدر ما انه رؤيه للاستقرار الاقتصادي
العالم يمر
باشكاليه اقتصاديه كبيره جدا المؤسسات
التقليديه الاقتصاديه العالميه ترهلت
ثقلت تبعاتها المحرك الاكبر
للمؤسسات الاقتصاديه الكبرى هو الاقتصاد
الغربي بالدرجه الاساس الاقتصاد الغربي
بالدرجه الاكبر على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الاسبوع الماضي كان اسبوع مخاض صعب
العجز عن سداد الدين الذي وصل الحد السقف
الاعلى العجز عن الوصول الى حل اصبح هناك
تصادميه ما بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
عدم السداد معناتها انهيار مؤسسات ماليه
امريكيه كبرى
للتوافق على رفع سقف الدين معناه تضخيم
الدين وحل مؤقت يتوازن مع هذا وهذا اشك
عدم الوصول في البيت الابيض الى ما يسمى
التكتيك فيما يتصل بالموازنه من حيث
الالتزامات والمدفوعات هذه اشكاليه كبيره
جدا تؤثر على المؤسسات الاقتصاديه وتنعكس
على اقتصاديات الدول لو نظرنا في في
المؤسسات التقليديه خلفها مجموعه من القوه
الدوليه القوه الدوليه عددها قليل يعني
خمس قوه دوليه اذا اخرجها منها روسيا
والصين اصبحنا امام التكتل الجديد القوه
الصاعده كما تسمى او القوه لا نسميها
حقيقه وسواء الاقتصاديات الصاعده الدول
الصاعده القوه المتوسطه هي تمثل الشريحه
الاكبر عن مستوى المجتمع الدولي وهي التي
تمثل التوجه الان للاتجاه الى بريكس وهذا
سيعطي مؤشرات اضافيه اخرى المؤشر الاساسي
هو عمليه زياده المساحه الجغرافيه التي
تتنفس فيها الان بريكس تتنفس بما يزيد عن
27% من مساحه اليابسه تتحرك في فضاء 50%
من الديموغرافيه العالميه
تتكا على مؤسسه اقتصاديه ضخمه جدا اللي هي
الصين وتتكئ على عمق استراتيجي اللي هي
مضمه شنغهاي لان روسيا والصين الفاعلين
الرئيسين في هذه المنظه وهم الفاعلون
الرئيسيون الان في مجموعه البركس اذا
الدول الصاعده او بما يسمى حتى في المصطلح
الغربي يسمونها المجتمع العالم الجنوبي
الكبير وتدخل فيها مجموعه اندونيسيا تدخل
فيها ماليزيا تدخل فيها سنغافور تدخل فيها
تايلاند هذه القوه الان هي تبحث عن حل لما
بعد الازمه لان العالم الان المظله جديده
عن ليست هذه نقطه مهمه هي ليست مظله جديده
بالمفهوم الوظيفي هو متنفس جديد في حال
تجذرت الانكسارات في المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
الدوليه لان عمليه اي انكسار في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سوف تتعطل الحركه
الدنماركيه المؤسسات الاقتصاديه التقليديه
يبقى عندنا اشكال اشكال الاشكال الرئيسي
عندنا الاساسي ان المحللين والمراقبين
الاقتصاديين لا زالت المعياريه لديهم في
النظر الى البدائل هو المعيار التقليدي
المؤسسات التي اعتادوا عليها وكنا عايشنا
هذه التجربه في اوبك اوبك بلس حينما تحررت
من المعياريه التقليديه استطعت اوبك ان
ترسم استراتيجيه مجموعه بريكس تحتاج الى
ان تتحرر من التحليلات الاقتصاديه
التقليديه
التي تنظر لنفسها ليست بديل وليست لمواجهه
الدولار
وزحزحه الدولار وانما ان يتنفس العالم
اقتصادا جديدا لان الاقتصاد
التقليدي بنى على النفعيه المباشره للقوه
الاقتصاديه الداعمه سواء البنكيه او
الحكوميه واصبح ثقل على القوه الناميه
الان مجموعه بريكس انشات
ورد في التقرير يعني مخرجين اقتصاديين
جميلين بنك التنميه
والصندوق الاحتياطي صندوق قبل قبل ان نخوض
اكثر في التفاصيل هذه بالنسبه لدول مثلا
مثل السعوديه او مصر او الامارات عندما
تريد ان تلتحق بهذه المجموعه اي فوائد
يمكن ان تجنيها الفائده المباشره انك
ستخرج من قيود السوفت قيود السوفت هي
عقوبات على الصين عقوبات على على روسيا
هذه الدول لها علاقات واسعه النظام
التحويلات الماليه الان هذا عندهم نظام
ميرو وفي نظام الان اخر يطرح وسيصبح في
يعني تنفس للتعامل الثنائي الثنائي بعيد
عن الضغوط والعقوبات والقيود التي فرضت
المؤسسه قد تكون اماني اكثر منها اهداف
ممكن ان تتحقق بسهوله يعني هذا هذا ما
ينشد الجميع الوصول اليه ولكن هي وقائع
تدريجيه تتنامى الان واخذت مساحات متوسعه
جدا الان الق وه الاساسيه استاذ محمد
والذي يجب يدركها العالم حقيقه ولكن لا
يتكلم بها عاليا
ان النفط والغاز من اكبر المحركات في
عمليه التنفس على مستوى العملات الثنائيه
وذلك مثلا دول كثيره الان المنتجه للنفط
والغزوه تتنفس مع الصين باللووان الصيني
هذا بالنسبه للدول الراغبه ولكن بالنسبه
للدول المؤسسه سيد
من من موسكو هذه الدول كيف ينظر اليها هذه
الدول التي تريد ان تلتحق بالبريكس هل
يمكن ان تشكل ايه اضافه لهذه المجموعه في
نواتها الاولى
انا متاكد ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات العربيه المتحده لاعبان مهمان
ليس في قط فقط منطقه الخليج بل في العالم
بشكل عام لذلك
فان التعاون هما مع بريك سيكون هاما وهذا
لا يعني بالضروره انهم اصبحان عضوان في
بريكس غدا ولكن هناك انواع مختلفه من
التعاون وبعض اشكال هذا التعاون هم فعلا
قد بداوا فيه
على سبيل المثال نعرف ان بنك التنميه
الجديد
يعمل
مع دول الخليج وهذه العمليه ستستمر واذا
من نظرنا الى مناقشات الجاريه حاليا داخل
بريكس فثمت مفهومان حول تطوير المؤسسات
بعض البعض يقول بان المؤسسات ينبغي ان
تنمو كارقام كاعداد وان تقبل على الاقل
خمسه دول جدا وهذه السنه وربما لاحقا قبول
سبع او حتى عشر اعضاء جدا والنقطه الاخرى
او الراي الاخر هو انه بدل من زياده عدد
الاعضاء ينبغي ان يكون لدينا شيئا يسمونه
يسمونه
المتمثل معظم كل قراته الناطق العالم يمكن
ان يعملوا مع شركاء رئيسيين ليس بالضروره
كاعضاء كامله عضويه بل حلفاء او كشركاء
يمكن ان ينضم الى مشاريع محدده بذاتها ضمن
ذلك طبعا التجاره النفط التي في غايه
الاهميه بالنسبه لجميع عمل في بريكس فبعض
الدول هي منتجه للنفط مثل روسيا ولكن هناك
مستهلكين كبيرين للنفط مثل الصين والهند
وبالتالي يبقى النفط عنصر هاما جدا ولكن
المشكله سيد كورتنوف ان لم تحدد بعد
معايير القبول او الرفض لاعضاء جدود هذه
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى الصين تبدو مرحبه
بانضمام اعضاء جدد بينما نجد مثلا الهند
او جنوب افريقيا ما زالت حذره في هذه
المساله كيف ستحسم
في الواقع اولا انا اتفق تماما معك انه
ليس هناك اجراءات محدده بذاته حول طريقه
قبول عضويه جديده هناك حاله واحده جرى
فيها قبول عضو جديد هو كانت جنوب افريقيا
وحاليا طبعا
البعض يرى بان توسيع
عضويه او هيكل البريكس قد يعقد في مساله
تعميق بحيث ان الهيكل يصبح اكثر رحاله
اما الراي الاخر وهو قبول اعضاء جدا فان
ذلك قد تصبح اكثر شرعيه كمؤسسه عالميه
واعتقد انهم سيستمرون في مناقشه هذه
المواضيع حملنا الان حتى شهر اغسطس اب
القادم عندما تعقل للقمه في جوهانسبرج
وانا ذاك
توصلنا الى معايير اكثر تحديدا لقبول
الاعضاء الجدد هل ينظر في الولايات
المتحده الدكتور مصطفى شاهين الى كل هذا
الحراك وهذه الرغبه في توسيع بريكس على
انها مساله ربما تزيد من القلق الامريكي
تجاه هذه المساله
اولا دعني ارحب بحضرتك يا استاذ محمد
حضرتك الكرام وبكافه الساده المشاهدين في
العالم العربي
الحقيقه سؤال حضرتك مهم جدا للغايه وحقيقه
هناك مثار للقلق داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خاصه للاسف الشديد مع تفاقم
ازمه المديونيه الامريكيه واحنا شاهدنا
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
الجدال داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بين الحزبين الرئيسيين بين الحزب الجمهوري
والحزب الديمقراطي في قضيه رفع سقف الديون
قضيه رفع سقف الديون مرتبطه جدا بازمه
الدولار ان اذا حدث
ونقصت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن
التزاماتها وهذا مستحيل انها تعمل له ان
هذا سيضر قوه الدولار الامريكي في النظر
عامه الدول خاصه اذا احنا عرفنا ان 90%
90% من الاحتيا الدوليه لدى الدول او لدى
البنوك المركزيه محتفظين بها بالدولار
الامريكي
التعاملات باليوان الصيني لا تتجاوز 5%
حتى هذه اللحظه لكن القلق داخل امريكا وده
الحقيقه له تفسيرات كثيره جدا من ان هنالك
صعود صيني وكان هنالك اتفاقات امنيه بين
الصين وبين امريكا على اعتبار ان امريكا
كانت هي السوق الاول للصين حجم التجاره
الدوليه بين الاتنين قرابه 500 مليار
دولار فقط صادرات الصينيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا التخوفات داخل
امريكا
جعلت ان امريكا تنظر وبحذر شديد نحو بدائل
او شركاء تجاريين اخرين بدلا من الصين على
الناحيه الاخرى امريكا تخشى ان هنالك
تحالف بين الصين وبين روسيا
وتركيا وايران عشان هذا تحالف قوي ومؤثر
جدا خاصه في منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا مع هذه
التحالفات التحالف الاخطر بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه اللي مرتبط
جدا بالنسبه لسياساتها انها مش قضيه انها
تخشى ضعف الدولار بل بالعكس من مصلحه
امريكا ان يكون الدولار ضعيفا ليس من
مصلحه امريكا ان يكون الدولار قوي لكن ما
حدث والحكومه الامريكيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تستوعب بعد تداعيات هذا القرار ان الحكومه
الامريكيه بعد غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا فرضت
حظر وتجميد لكل الاصول الروسيه بما يقدر ب
300 مليار دولار فالان امريكا اعطت رساله
الى الدول الاخرى سواء دول في منطقتنا
العربيه او في اي دوله في العالم ان انت
بين يوم وليله روسيا اللي عندها احتياطيات
دوليه ضخمه جدا بره بما يقدر 300 مليار
دولار
عجزت ولا اول مره عن سداد مديونيتها ليس
لان ما عندهاش احتياطيات بل عندها
احتياطيات تفوق دونها بكثير ولكن لقوه
الاداره الامريكيه وفرض الاداره الامريكيه
عقوبات وشاركها الاتحاد الاوروبي في فرض
العقوبات على روسيا فرسيا والصين الان وكل
الدول الاخرى التي لديها احتياطيات او
استثمارات بره كل الان بيفكر تفكير جدي
ماذا لو ان الولايات المتحده فرضت علي
ايضا حظر على اموال او استثمارات في
الخارج
هذا سؤال مهم جدا ربما الدكتور ماجد
التركي
عن ان يعني ربما
هناك نوع من مسجد اماني
بالوقائع بمعنى انه البعض يريد ان يكسر
هذه الهيمنه الامريكيه ويريد ان يوسع
البريكس اعتقاد منه انه سيكون له مستقبل
ولكن الولايات المتحده ما زالت قادره على
التاثير في الامور الاقتصاديه وبالتالي
ليس من السهل تحدي بين قوسين الهيمنه
الامريكيه الاقتصاديه الان
نتفق مع كليا وذلك لذلك انا احاول ان
نستبعد فلسفه التحدي ولو رجعنا الى اول
قمه للبريكس في 2009 المحور الاساسي في
القمه ما هو هو ايجاد تدابير لحل الازمات
واصلاح المؤسسات الماليه التقليديه هي لم
تنشا لتكون بديل او او تواجه المنظومات
التقليديه ولكن لتصلح هذه المنظومات لما
وجدت هذه المنظومات تتجذر فيها الاشكاليه
وتتحول الى ادوات لبعض القوى مقابل العالم
لان العالم ليس العالم الغربي العالم ليس
فقط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه العالم
متعدد لذلك اصبح هناك الاشكاليه في نقطه
في تقديري ملفته وقد تكون مفيده وهي ترتبط
بسؤال يعني مهم جدا اثرت قبل قليل لقضيه
الاليات في مجموعه الان مجموعه البريكس
الاشكاليه التي
لم تحدد بعد يعني ستدرس من يدخل لا يدخل
ربما تصبح مغريه ضم السعوديه او الامارات
او او ايران كدول نفطيه موازنه ولكن ربما
دول اخرى تسعى والجزائر ربما ايضا ولكن
ربما دول اخرى لا لا
على كلنا نعرف الان هو الاشكاليه
الاشكاليه منين في مجموعه عده المجاميع
التي تنشا هي تنشا بناء على توافقيه
مكانيه او تحديات مشتركه لو تلاحظ مجموعه
البريكس اقتصادياتها غير منسجمه اساسا
وجغرافيه متباعده يعني مثلا الصين
سيد
بالنسبه
للرغبه في كسر النمط الاقتصادي العالمي
الذي تهيمن عليه الولايات المتحده اذا
اخذنا مثلا مقالته الامريكيه
قال قالت تحول الى كابوس بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده لان تنامي البريكس يعني تراجع
الولايات المتحده ولكن في المقابل ايضا
دوله مثل روسيا
تعاني من مشاكل خاصه بعد حرب اوكرانيا
والعقوبات المسلطه عليها وبالتالي تبدو هي
في غير
امكانيه ان ان تصمد وان تكون نواه قويه
الى جانب الصين والهند في هذه المجموعه
اولا اود القول ان ان بريكس
ليس
يعني واحد او ذات الديني واحد فهذه الدول
مختلفه
فيما بينها واحيانا الدول الاعضاء تكون
علاقاتهم مختلفه فيما بينهم مثلا
العلاقه بين الصين والهند في العلاقات
بينهما ليست سهله والنقطه الثانيه هي طبعا
ان بريكس تحاول ان تكون هيئه جامعه اي
تحاول ان تبقى متساويه فمثلا لو اخذنا بنك
التنميه الجديد لبريكس نرى ان كل اعضاء
لديها حصص متساويه في هذا البنك هذا
المصرف
وهذا يختلف عن صندوق النقد الدولي اما
فيما يتعلق الولايات المتحده فاعتقد
طبعا ان الدولار يبقى هو
العمله الدوليه والعالميه الاكثر اهميه
لكن دوره دولار يتراجع بمرور الزمن وهذا
التراجع تزايد نتيجه الازمه
عندما ذلك قررت الولايات المتحده تحرير
الاصول الروسيه وهذه الازمه ستستمر عفوا
قرار تجميد هذه الاصول الروسيه
ونرى ان معظم التجاره حاليا تجري بالعلم
المحليه الوطنيه ولكن هذا طريق طويل لان
قوه الولايات المتحده ليس محدوده فقط
بالدولار في الولايات المتحده تسيطر
وتهيمن على الكثير من المؤسسات الماليه
العالميه
وتي تحدد المعايير الماليه
وان مصاريفها
وصناديقها الاستثماريه وشركات التامينيه
قويه جدا
لهذا طريق طويل امام بريكس وتحالفه
لحل الدولار بدء يحل محل الدولار بعمل
اخرى عمله رئيسيه للتعامل حتى فيما بين
الدول الاعضاء
النظام العالمي اذا الامر سيتحصل تغيير
لكن الامر يطلب وقتا طويلا هذا الوقت
الطويل سيد كرتون اشار اليه بعض الخبراء
الى ان الموعد سيكون في 2050 بمعنى اذا
سارت الامور بهذه الوتيره يفترض ان تتغير
الكثير من قواعد اللعبه وتتراجع الهيمنه
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه ولكن اذا توقفت لو
سمحت عند بنك التنميه الجديد الذي اشرت
اليه وهو بنك يريد او يطمح الى ان يكون
بنك العالمي الجديد او او صندوق النقد
الدولي الجديد هل تعتقد ان له امكانيه
فعلا على مدار السنوات المقبله ان ان
يتحدى البنك الدولي او صندوق النقد الدولي
في مشمولات مد قروض لبعض الدول
اعتقد ان الطموح موجود نعم وانا بنك
التنميه الجديد ما زال
متواضع نسبيا رغم اصوله عامه لديه حواليه
مئه مليار دولار وهذا ليس بالمبلغ الصغير
ولكن سيكون صعب عليه ان يتنافس مع البنك
الدولي
ولكن نستطيع ان نرى ان هذا مؤسسه حيويه
جدا ومهنيه جدا ومؤهله جدا وتنمو بسرعه
شديده ونرى انه فعلا بداوا
بوضع عشرات مليارات الدولارات في مشاريع
استثماريه وغير محدوده على اعضاء البريكس
فهناك مشاريع في افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه والشرق الاوسط واعتقد ان هذا
البنك لديه اعمامه مستقبل ناصع
كما هم بالمحافظه على معايير مهنيه قويه
واثبات التزامهم والاستمرار في التزامهم
بما نسميه التنميه المستدامه هذا امر
اساسي لنتعلق البنى التحتيه وليس
بالمضاربات وعلى كل موعد 2050 دكتور شاهين
يعني قله عديد الخبراء من بينهم هذا
الخبير الذي اريد ان استشهد به جيم اونيل
في كبير الخبراء في جولد من
مؤسسه الخدمات الماليه والاستثماريه
الامريكيه توقع هيمنه هذه الاقتصادات
مجتمعه اقتصادات البريكس على العالم في
2050 هل ترى ذلك ممكنا
هو الحقيقه خليني اقولها لحضرتك بكل وضوح
احنا يا استاذ محمد عشان نعمل تكتل
اقتصادي وتستطيع ان تصل من هذا التكتل
لعمله موحده ده يعني مثلا خدام حضرتك
نموذج الاتحاد الاوروبي بدا بمجمع الحديد
والصلب يمكن من منتصف الخمسينات من القرن
الماضي ثم جاءت اتفاقيه ماستر يمكن 1992
ثم خرج لنا اليورو سنه 1997 استغرقت
تقريبا 50 عاما قبل هذه الخطوه تم في
اتفاقات تم فيه وضع تعريفات جمركيه محدده
تم وضع سوق مشتركه تم وضع حقوق وقوانين
لحريه انتقال رؤوس الاموال بين الدول
انتقالات للعماله بين الدول
سياسات نقديه موحده بنك مركزي موحد هناك
اجراءات كثيره جدا عشان انت تطلع من
البريكس توصل ان يكون منافس قوي للاتحاد
الاوروبي خلي بال حضرتك الان ان داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي وداخل امريكا هناك غليان
شديد جدا خاصه مع الظروف الاقتصاديه
الصعبه اللي بدانا نشاتها في اوروبا شفنا
مظاهرات في فرنسا شفنا افلاس في اليونان
شفنا وضع اقتصادي صعب في اسبانيا شفنا ان
بلد زي انجلترا انسحبت من الاتحاد
الاوروبي كل هذا العوامل اللي قدام حضرتك
هي انعكاس لقوه الاقتصاد الصيني
لان هروب المنتجين الامريكان وهروب
المنتجين الاوروبيين من الضرائب المرتفعه
في اوروبا ويذهب لينتج داخل الصين هو
حقيقه اكسب الصين قوه كبيره جدا اعطى له
قوه سوء وعرف الصينيين اسرار الصناعه
واصبح المنتج الذي يباع داخل امريكا هو
نفسه المنتج اللي بيباع في جنوب افريقيا
او في القاهره او في ليبيا او في المغرب
او في الجزائر
فهذه التطورات بدات تجعل الشيء من
الشعبويه او شيء من الصراع الداخلي داخل
المجتمع الاوروبي نفسه وداخل مجتمع
الامريكي نفسه هذه الصراعات هيبدا رجال
السياسه الامريكان والاوروبيين انه يفكر
يا عمنا انا ليه بروح انتج في الصين وبقى
ادخل عندي ما انا دلوقتي بقوي الصين
وحلفائها ولا يقبل ابدا وعشان الناس تبقى
واضح لديها الرؤيه تماما اياك انك تتوقع
ان البنك البريكس البنك
التنميه الجديد اللي هم عايزين يعملوه
اللي مقره شنغهاي في الصين لن يكون بنكا
خيريا لمساعده الفقراء او الدول التي
تحتاج الى اقراض هو طريقه جديده لفرض
السيطره او الهيمنه الصينيه والامريكان
يرون ذلك صراحه والامريكان يعلمون علمي
يقين ان التحدي الاكبر لهم الان اصبح هو
الصين ومن جاورها او ومن اتفق معها
فامريكا واوروبا الان ترى ذلك رؤيا العين
ان قضيه ان يترك للصين ان تكون هي الورشه
الوحيده للعالم وان تكون هي الدوله
المنتجه في العالم وانها تحدث هذه
الاتفاقات سواء طريق الحرير سواء ان تصدر
وتمتلك الاسواق العالميه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واوروبا الان تستشعر بهذا الخطر
الشديد وهذا في حد ذاته لنا نحن في الدول
العربيه في الدول الفقيره في الدول
المتوسطه هذا مكسب عظيم جدا لان الصراع
بين القوتين العظمتين هتعطيني بدائل اكبر
وهتبدا حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تبدا تفكر في حساباتها حساباتها
الاقتصاديه وحساباتها السياسيه لا يمكن ان
انت عشان تعاقب روسيا وتفرض الهيمنه
الامريكيه في المنطقه انك انت معاقبتك
روسيا الان انت الان داخل امريكا حتى
علماء عظام زي مثلا
رائد المدرسه الواقعيه الامريكيه ورائد من
رواد وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه قال لهم لا
يمكن ان انا اترك روسيا تبقى في حضن الصين
ولذلك هناك مساعي حسيسه وهناك ستكون خطط
كبيره جدا في الفتره المقبله يعني
قضيه يعني اسمح لي قضيه العمله الجديده
الان الكل يتحدث عن هذه العمله الجديده هل
هل من السهل يعني مثلا
بوست مثلا اعتبرت انه كل قصه البريكس هذه
سمتها تمرين تافهه يعني هجوم البريكس على
الدولار او محاوله تعويضه هو تمرين تافه
هذا تعبيره تقول بان الدولار سيظل سيظل هو
الملك سيظل هو على العرش
قصه البحث عن عمله اخرى عالم يه تراها
مساله ممكنه
لا هو المشكله مش في الممكنه الصين اكبر
دوله مستفيده الان من قوه الدولار
الامريكي الصين بتدعي ربنا ليله نهار ان
الدولار يرتفع ويرتفع كلما ارتفع الدولار
كلما استطاعت ان تسيطر هي على الاسواق
العالميه ولن تستطيع قوه الدولار الامريكي
ان يجعل الصادرات الامريكيه تنفذ الى
الاسواق لو حضرتك رجعت بالذاكره شويه
للخمسينات والستينات هتلاقي المنطقه
العربيه بالكامل كان يغزوها الانتاج
الامريكي بمجرد قوه الدولار الامريكي وضعف
اليوان الصيني وانا بعض اساتذتنا دايما
كانوا يقولوا لي هذا الكلام هنا في امريكا
ان في حتى امريكا بتطلب من الصين ان ترفع
اليوان فليس من مصلحتها اولا ليس من مصلحه
الصين ان اليوان الصيني يبقى له قوه لان
لو اصبح اليوان الصيني القوي هذا سيحكم
الصادرات الصينيه وهم مش عايزين كده دي
اول نقطه ثانيا كونك انك الدول الاعضاء
داخل منظومه سيؤدي الى هلاك المنظمه كامله
لان انا عندي بعض القيود بضعها خاصه في
الموازنات العامه للدوله مثلا لو انت ضميت
بلد مثلا زي مصر مثلا يعني عشان انا يعني
اعلى درايه اكثر اذا ارتفع معدل التضخم في
مصر حتما سيؤثر على قيمه العمله وهذا لن
يقبلوا ابدا ان هذا يكون موجود فالحقيقه
للاسف الشديد هي قضيه الصراع موجود وليس
من مصلحتهم ان هو يتنافس مع الدولار لان
اولئك في هذه الحاله فقط داخل الدولار
نفسه في هذه الحلقه دكتور ماجد التركي
كاننا امام مشهد صراع بين عملاقين بالاساس
الولايات المتحده والصين
وبعض الدول خاصه الدول التي ترغب في
الانضمام البريكس كانها تذهب من اسمح لي
من مصيبه الى مصيبه اخرى لان ايضا الصين
ليست جمعيه خيريه البنك الذي اشار اليه
ايضا ليس بديلا خيريا لصندوق النقد الدولي
او البنك العالمي وبالتالي وكان هذه الدول
التي جاءت في الوسط
ترى في هذا البديل افضل في حين انه ليس
بالضروره افضل
استاذ محمد هذه قوه الاعلام الغربي في
التاطير الذهني استطاع ان يؤطر حتى النخب
عندنا او النخب حتى في دائره البركس فيما
يتصل والتصادميه مع الدولار او المؤسسات
التقليديه
البريكس في فلسفته حسب ما افهم هو حاضنه
امنه
لجميع من الاقتصاديات في حدوث انهيارات او
انكسارات في الاقتصاد العالمي لانه العقد
العالمي على شفير انهيارات وتحديات عميقه
جدا هذه هذه نقطه
النقطه الثانيه في في تقدير ان ان القراءه
السياسيه
ترجعنا الى المؤسسات التقليديه هل الدول
الان هي اعضاء
كل منظمه في المنظمات الاقتصاديه الدوليه
اطلاقا هي هي علاقات فليس بالضروره ان
تصبح الدول عضويه في بريكس حتى تستفيد من
بنك التنميه او ان تراهن سياسيا على هذا
المسار وتخالف هذا المثل ليس بالضروره ان
تتخذ موقفا من احد الطرفين ولكن ممكن ان
تتعاون مع بنك التنميه اللي طرحته الاصيل
وفعلا انا اتفق مع فكره ان الصين هي ليست
لا تقدم نفس عن جمعيه اجتماعيه بالعكس هي
تسعى الى نفوذ
ولها الان سلوكيات سلبيه في مناطق النفود
في اسيا الوسطى من خلال الاقراض خلال
ثلاثين سنه الماضيه
لاستحواذ الجغرافي الان هي تستحوج جغرافيا
على المناطق الدول التي تعجز عن سدد الدين
وهذه نقطه خطيره جدا وهذه عيدنا الى تجربه
المكسيك والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دائما هيمنه القوه الكبرى وان تبقى في قوه
صغرى هند الاشكاليه نحن نتامل على ان
بريكس ستكون حاضنه للقوه المتوسطه التي
تمثل النسبه الاكبر عدديا وجغرافيا
وديموقراطيا في العالم حتى نحدث التوازن
النقطه في تقدير الاخرى والمهمه
اننا
امام مرحله في تقديري ليست عشرين خمسين
كما يقول خبراء وهذه دائما دراسات الحين
نسميها الدراسات التوجيهيه للاذهان لان في
تصور الذي يقرا المشهد الاقتصادي الدولي
والتحديات العميقه لان نحن مقبلين على
انهيارات ستبتدا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنتقل الى اوروبا اوروبا قاره
عجوز فقيره ترى اوروبا لا تمتلك الا
الصناعه ليس فيها مواد اوليه ترى القاره
الاوروبيه يعني احنا نشوف الموقف بينه
وبين الافارقه انما الافارقه طردت كثير من
الشركات الاوروبيه اصبحت شركات الاوروبيه
تتسول العلاقات مع الدول البديله هذه
قضايا لا بد ان تجمع وتوضع على الطاوله
بنستبعد القرار السياسي في التحكيم
لمجموعه البريكس وننظر اليها كانها حاضنه
في حال حدوث ازمات اقتصاديه عالميه هل ليس
فقط حاضنه هل يمكن اعتبارها احد ادوات
الضغط على الولايات المتحده بمعنى هذه
الدول التي ترغب في الانضمام البريكس
والدول التي واقعه تحت
طهر صندوق النقد الدولي او القروض كانها
توجه رساله للولايات المتحده نحن لدينا
بدائل اخرى اذا لم تطوروا او تحسنوا طريقه
تعاملكم الاقتصاديه معكم معنا وتخفف من
ضغوطات الاقتصاديه فاننا لدينا بدائل هل
هل هذه اللعبه يمكن ان تنجح ستنجح واضف
عليها ما اشرت اليه قبل قليل وهو قضيه
العقوبات العالم لا يريد ان يبقى تحت ضغوط
او تحت عقوبات او ان يفاجئ يوما ما ان
ارصده جمدت لذلك الجانب الغربي ان لا اقول
له الامريكيه هو الان يشعر بان الخطوات
تتسارع في اغلاق منافذ القوه لديه المنافذ
القوه فيما يتصل بالمؤسسات الاقتصاديه
ومخرجاتها الكثير من الدول تتدمر من صندوق
النقد الدولي اصبحت اصبح دخول صندوق النقد
الدولي الى اي دوله هو مؤشر على اشكاليات
متجذره في الاقتصاد والاجتماع في اي دوله
يكون ص النقد الدولي حاضرا فيها في نهايه
الحلقه نقوم بجوله بين ضيوفنا لنرى
توقعاتهم بالنسبه لقمه البريكس في اغسطس
اب المقبل في جنوب افريقيا اذا تاكد تماما
في جنوب افريقيا لان هناك اشكال ايضا
يتعلق بحضور الرئيس بوتين نريد ان نسال
ضيفنا في موسكو ثم ضيفنا في مسجد وننتهي
هنا في الاستوديو ما توقعاتكم بالنسبه
لقضيه توسيع البريكس او قضيه العمله
الموحده او غيرها من القضايا التي تتوقع
ان تحسمها القمه المقبله في اغسطس اب
المقبل نبدا بالسيد قلت نوف
اولا اعتقد انه من المحتمل انه في هذه
السنه تحصل على اعضاء جدد ليس واحده
واثنين بل ربما عدد اكبر حتى يصل الى
الخمسه ومن المحتمل ان نشهد اجراءات جديده
للتنظيم عمليه الانضمام الى بريكس بطريقه
اكثر تنظيما ثانيا لا اعتقد ان سيكون
لدينا عمله موحده
او قد نشهد السله من العملات الوطنيه
تستخدم بشكل اكثر في التبادلات التجاريه
بين الدول البريكس وكما ناقشنا ذلك هذه
عمليه طويله ولكن الاتجاه واضح واخيرا انا
فعلا امل
ان موضوع مشاركه الرئيس بوتين في قمه
بريكس سوف تحل هذه القضيه بشكل ايجابي
ولكن في حاله انه لم تحل فهناك خيارات
بديله للمشاركه عن بعد نعلم انه اثناء
جائحه الكورونا كنا تدنى على ان نقوم
بمشاركه في الاجتماعات عن بعد وبالتالي
هذه ليس للمشكله كبيره نعم دكتور شاهين
الحقيقه انا ارى ان اول مكسب كبير جدا
للبريكس هو توطيد العلاقات التجاريه بين
الدول الاعضاء وده هيدي قيمه عظمى اكبر
للصين تحديدا اكثر من الدول الاخرى وحتما
بالنسبه لروسيا هيكون منفذ كبير جدا انها
توطد علاقتها مع الصين ان لم تذهب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا الى
روسيا حتى تعيد مره اخرى او تعيد تجدد
العلاقه مره اخرى مع روسيا
وتوقف الحرب بينها وبين اوكرانيا هذا
الامر قد يعيد مره اخرى المياه الى
مجاريها بين روسيا واوروبا خاصه روسيا كان
لها دور كبير جدا لحمايه اوروبا الامر
الاخر المهم قضيه العمله الموحده انا لا
اعتقد ان ذلك سيحدث حتى في 2050 اللهم الا
اذا هنالك كان تنسيق عالي جدا في السياسات
الاقتصاديه والسي النقديه بين الدول
الاعضاء وهذا سيكون ضد مصلحه الصين فليس
من مصلحه الصين ان يكون هنالك عمله موحده
لكن من مصلحه الصين جدا انها تجعل صفقات
متكافئه مع الدول بحيث ممكن تصدر مثلا
لجنوب افريقيا سلع وخدمات وتاخذ من
افريقيا من جنوب افريقيا الذهب افريقيا
جنوب افريقيا هي الدوله رقم تسعه في
العالم في انتاج الذهب فاذا استطاعت انها
تعمل مثل هذه الصفقات المتبادله هتحقق
الصين مكاتب العظيمه والصين الان زي ما
قلت لحضرتك للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واوروبا الان الموضوع اصبح في مرمى
النيران الاوروبيه والامريكيه في السياسات
الاقتصاديه التي ستتبع خلال الفتره
المقبله لم يسمح بهذا الوضع العالمي ان
تكون دوله واحده هي المتسيده على عالم في
الانتاج الصناعي لن يسمح بهذا الامر دكتور
تركي
فهي نقاط سريعه انا اتصور ان كبرياء روسيا
لن تقبل عدم حضور الرئيس بوتين
وهذا هذا الحديث عن امكانيه نقلها الى الى
الى دوله اخرى القمه هي نفس الاشكاليه
لان جنوب افريقيا ملزمه
بالتصريحات
جنوب افريقيا سمعت لهم تصريحات سياسيه
عليا بانهم لن يلتزموا بهذا الامر وهذا
الامر لم ينطبق على اي رئيس دوله السابق
هذا امر الاخر في تقدير ان الانشغال
بالعمله الموحده العمله البديله غير عملي
غير منطقي في سياق العملات الرقميه التي
اتجه لها العالم العالم الان يتحرك من
خلال العملات الرقميه الصين رائده في هذا
الامر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اسست
عمله دولار موازيه للعمله الرقميه للعمله
الورقيه ستكون بديل عن الدولار الورقي
لذلك التفكير في عمله موحده بديله في
تصوري نوع من التاطير كما قلت ولكن العالم
متجه الى جانب العملات الرقميه النقطه
الاخيره موضوع الذهب في تقدير سيبقى
المعيار الوازن للمرحله الانتقاليه او
مرحله الانكشاريه ولكن
ستكون مساحه
اضافيه للتنفس الاقتصادي متعدد المجالات
للقوى الصاعده هل تتوقع في قمه جنوب
افريقيا انضمام اشر ضيفنا من موسكو الى
امكانيه انضمام اربعه وخمسه هل يمكن ان
تكون السعوديه من بينهم مثلا او الاكثر
حظا في الالتحاق انا متفائل باكثر من هذا
متفائل بان الدوره القادمه ستكون المملكه
هي هي رئيسه الدوره القادمه وتستضيف
الدوره القادمه في الرياض هذا توقعي وهذا
من خلال اجتماعات سمو وزير خارجيه يعني
بعد جنوب افريقيا جنوب افريقيا في عام 23
ناقص في عام 24 انا اتوقع ان تكون عضو
وانها ستستضيف هذه القمه هذه قراءتي
الخاصه في هذا وتصبح
بركس بلس على على وزن اوبك بلس بالنسبه
للدول الطامحه في الانضمام مثل السعوديه
والامارات وغيرها هل تعتقد الانضمام سيشكل
اضافه لهذه المجموعه ويعطيها اشعاع اكبر
في المرحله المقبله اضافه تبادليه في
تقديري اضافه تبادليه عميقه جدا لانها
ستخلق نوع من التنوع ستخلق نوع من التوازن
حتى الجانب الامريكي يشعر
بالثقل العلاقات لانه في شراكه استراتيجيه
ما بين الامارات والسعوديه مع روسيا ومع
الصين ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ماجد التركي شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من موسكو انوف لضيفنا من
الدكتور مصطفى شاهين شكرا لكم جميعا بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام يكونوا قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم بامان الله
[موسيقى]